[Music]
the racial issue in the united states is
often framed too
in terms of discrimination against
blacks on the part of caucasians and
let's say the white supremacy that has
emerged as a consequence of that but
that also um seems to fail as a
hypothesis given the staggering success
let's say of
indian americans and of asian americans
in general
because if it was a an issue that was
somehow related to the caucasian
community
per se you'd think that we they
would have been just as efficient at
holding back the progress of those other
groups as
holding back the progress of the black
community i feel like asian americans
aren't even involved they're
they're doing really well and we're
squabbling about race problems
yeah it's strange that it's it does seem
like that i don't
i don't really understand that um their
success is an embarrassment
to the theory um that white supremacy is
crushing
um how do you for example uh
say what what has been said about
standardized test scores
standardized tests rather like the sat
and act that they are
they are created by europeans for
europeans and are culturally biased in
very subtle ways that you know
there's some hand waving that's done
here but the point is the test is made
by white people for white people
and then asians come with no particular
background in european culture and
destroy the white people on this test
right on average so again it's an
embarrassment to the theory
that all of society is tilted um
in in favor of white people in subtle
and not so subtle ways
and a lot of that with the asians a lot
of that does seem to be a consequence of
of work habits i mean i looked into
asian versus caucasian performance in
the u.s
a number of decades ago for a federal
government project that i was doing at
the time
and this was the children of first
generation asian immigrants because the
effect seems to go away by about three
generations
maybe because their asians are more
thoroughly enculturated into the
american community but
the children of first generation asian
immigrants worked hard enough
so that that served as the equivalent to
15 additional iq points
which is roughly the difference between
the typical state university student and
the typical high school
student so that's a good example too of
of of a situation where cultural
differences really seem to play a role
yes and i've seen i've seen data to that
effect
uh in the u.s as well which suggests
that just you know it's not that
there's there's uh what's explaining it
is a genetic difference
it's that it's that you know it's like
more hours spent studying on average
it's
mom and dad over the shoulder um you
know
making sure that you do your homework
and you do it right
that phenomenon is not equally
represented in every culture
and it's underrepresented among black
americans
well that's that'll be a statement
that'll definitely make you popular
again
so what what makes you how do you know
that
good question um so that we do have we
do have survey evidence
uh you know on self-report
surveys of how how much
how many hours per night students
study brookings has done work on this
it's it's a it's a taboo subject so i
think most
academics understandably stay away from
it
we have extensive data from nielsen
which is a one of the leading market
research firms and
of the famous nielsen television ratings
which
investigate everything from what people
spend their money on to how many hours
of tv
people watch per day and breaks it down
by race
and you find big differences in all of
these things
differences that are consequential if
you
are concerned about closing gaps in
uh say wealth accrual and income
and and all of these things
you